you might have seen the headlines about
this thing a ten thousand dollar limited
edition gucci branded gaming console in
a special box
one of a hundred were made all custom
and now we got one right here so
might as well take it out the box shall
we i'll be honest i don't know i haven't
unboxed many gucci things but
there's a lot of leather
and gucci
x-box branding on it it actually smells
pretty good like it's leather so let's
uh let's open it up why not
one out of a hundred
[Music]
and there it is
it's the uh
it's the old green inside of a gucci box
we've all seen
actually oh here there's a uh
there's a game pass card so
somebody watching this just got a free
game pass so the inside this has some
pockets up here
okay let's get the
console out of here
okay
it's covered in gucci logos
from head to toe all the way around
uh not not on the back though just just
the front and the sides
and the rest is exactly like a normal
xbox series x i think i can put that
over here
[Music]
so you got your cables
normal hdmi cable normal power cable not
gucci branded cables
and then you have two controllers here
both of them also customized i've seen a
fair share of custom controllers in my
day
this one has the stripes the red and the
blue stripe
and the gucci font at the front
other than that normal black controller
oh and this is
one of 100 mk bhd edition so one of one
two so
they put mkbhd in green on the back oh
they put on the xbox too
there you go can you see that it says
mkbhd
on the gucci xbox
so technically this is an mkbhd gucci
collab right is that it i think that's
it oh this whole thing comes out
and then there's just more compartments
to buckle things in and it's all padded
and upholstered and
you can probably
repurpose this if you want this becomes
your
gucci
carrying case for something maybe you
take your xbox to the hotel with you
when you travel
this would be the uh
the place to carry this around
it's a lot
it's a lot
it's a lot
this is just ridiculous okay
just for the record i didn't uh buy or
customize this microsoft sent or gucci
sent it here to the studio so i don't
know who knows maybe i'll do a giveaway
of this uh
customized one of a hundred ten thousand
dollar xbox follow me on twitter for a
giveaway
of this xbox but let's take this
opportunity to talk about brand collabs
what they are
why they keep happening
and how we got here so we already know
brands just love to collaborate right
it's basically a corporate 101 strategy
for increasing brand awareness trying to
get something trending or capitalizing
on overlapping audiences oftentimes
they're really cringy but sometimes
sometimes you get something that's
pretty cool or even iconic there's nike
and playstation there's lego and ikea
uber and spotify doritos and taco bell
there was even a burger king and
mcdonald's collab believe it or not but
i want to talk about collaborations in
tech
because there are endless examples but
when i think about them in my head i
kind of divide them into two different
categories the ones that seem to make
sense
and then the ones that
seem kind of dumb so if you look at
something like apple and nike plus for
example
okay yeah makes perfect sense apple got
to add some fitness focused features to
their watch with a trusted partner to
attract more of the workout crowd and
nike gets a bunch of new customers using
nike products and exposed to the nike
brand via the machine that is apple
sales so basically it's a win win for
both companies or there was the oneplus
hasselblad collab earlier this year
that's again it makes sense it's a it's
a win-win oneplus has this new but
ongoing partnership where they get to
put the hasselblad name alongside their
smartphone cameras so that's a win for
oneplus because a lot of people who
trust the hasselblad name in photography
will now associate oneplus with high
quality cameras whether it's true or not
and it's the win for hasselblad a pretty
traditional old-timey camera company who
can now associate their name with an
upstart trendy smartphone company to
signal that they're high-tech and
fashion-forward you know this happens
with leica all the time too so whether
they're cringy or super corporate or not
whatever the vibe is there are a number
of brand collabs all around the tech
industry every year that makes sense
and then there are
monstrosities like this because on the
surface in the tech world this seems
dumb it's a gucci xbox why would that be
better than a regular xbox does a gucci
xbox perform or play games better in
some way do i get anything out of having
a gucci xbox of course not but if you've
noticed there's actually been a lot of
tech collaborations like this tech
companies collaborating with fashion
companies fashion brands so tech
products are in this weird place where
most of the stuff you buy is supposed to
be purely functional right you buy a
piece of tech because it accomplishes a
task or serves a certain function it's a
computer that does the thing you need it
to but not necessarily because of the
fashion
but whether we like to admit it or not
there is a personal element to all these
purchases i've always said the
smartphone you buy is actually one of
the most personal choices you make you
hold it every day you take it everywhere
with you it wakes you up in the morning
you feel kind of empty and lost without
it so even though it is just a piece of
tech it's no wonder the companies that
sell them want you to feel like they're
also pretty fashionable in addition to
being a good piece of tech you might
remember lg collaborated with prada on
smartphones three different times
samsung collaborated with hugo boss on a
smartphone back in 2008 and again in
2011 louis vuitton collaborated recently
with headphone maker master and dynamic
to sell some 995 earbuds there was a
gold dolce gabbana razor three a decade
ago and i think apple and hermes may be
the best example of them all
hermes
i never know if i'm saying that right
hermes
hermes hermes right but i just remember
so distinctly when the apple watch went
on sale the first one went on sale back
in 2015
and apple they of course made a couple
versions there was a black version and a
silver version it was stainless steel
but they wanted to of course signify
that it was fashionable because it's a
watch and they have to get the fashion
crowd to like it and so they made the
apple watch edition and this version was
plated in solid 18 karat gold and it
started at ten thousand dollars now
anybody already subscribed here to this
channel probably already knows that it's
a bad idea to drop 10 bands on a first
gen tech product
just because it's covered in gold and
you think it's fashionable but that
that's that's a real thing people did
that's out there like the real humans
actually spent that money on the first
gen apple watch tech blogs had a field
day with the headlines we already knew
this was coming but yeah a year later
there was a new one the addition was
discontinued
of course it turns out apple even as
massive and popular and successful and
wealthy as they are can't break into
fashion immediately just by themselves
on their own name and so shortly after
that we did see the beginning of that
hermes collaboration so that fashion
brand comes in they start to do custom
watch bands unique styles with leather
that match the watch faces and custom
packaging and higher prices because you
know it's fashion that's kind of the way
things work but that that collaboration
has been way more successful it
continues to this day and it's a win-win
for both companies hermes gets a much
more tech focused crowd and apple gets
to break into the much more
fashion-centric crowd so fundamentally
that's what they're always looking for
in these brand collaborations is a win
for both sides that win-win
kind of like mkbhd
and new channel sponsor cash app cash
app is incredible i get to share with
you guys they're the easiest way to send
spend and save money and you can buy
stocks or even bitcoin with a dollar so
if you use code marquez to sign up 15
bucks will appear in your account it's
not bad and then 10 will go to girls who
code link below but the point is the
point is this none of these
tech fashion collabs actually makes the
product better like
none of them that's not the point of
this type of collab now you could argue
that the tech on tech collabs actually
do you could say if oneplus and
hasselblad are collaborating that that
actually can make the camera in the
phone a bit better you could argue that
you could argue the nike plus and apple
sponsorship and collaboration actually
made a better product but
this is just a monogrammed
xbox series x it's not a better xbox uh
the dolce gabbana razer was just a gold
razor it's more about the experience of
taking it out of the box the custom
packaging the fashion nature of it
whatever you think about this fashion
that's what that collab is more about
and then there's also the x factor which
is just hype so brands have various
levels of this and in a world where the
playstation 5 from rival sony was pretty
much the most hyped thing in gaming for
a whole year around its release i mean
it's still impossible to get so
microsoft and their brand team is of
course looking for ways to get people
talking about and thinking about xbox
series x which came out around the same
time and what better way than by
creating a limited edition super hyped
special xbox with one of the most hyped
companies so even though the product
isn't actually better the hype and all
the brand awareness created by this
collab
is a win-win for both companies so
that's why the gucci xbox exists this
honestly probably would have been
received the exact same way if it was a
supreme xbox or i don't know louis
vuitton xbox it's just they just want
people saying xbox more you know and
it's working
is it's working isn't it i'm here
sitting on video talking about it and
now it's on youtube going into their
brand sentiment calculator and of course
there's no dislikes on this video so it
must be working but yeah the truth is i
divided them into two different
categories at the beginning of this
video those that seem to make sense and
those that don't but at the end of the
day when you look at it as a win-win in
some way they kind of all do make some
level of sense so i wouldn't be shocked
if we keep seeing
more of this type of stuff
thanks for watching catch the next one
peace
[Music]